so my project the last book the most
recent book is called the new meta
physicals and it's about spirituality in
America it's an ethnography I'm an
ethnographer which meant that I spent a
lot of time or for about two years
hanging out with people in Cambridge
Massachusetts people who consider
themselves spiritual not religious
although some are also religious the
project was prompted by a range of
questions I had had in the prior project
I had done I had met a lot of people who
were spiritual not religious people who
had variety of sort of what we might
call a HOD religious beliefs and since
that they didn't really align with
anything particularly religious very
devoted people and very interesting so I
wanted to sort of figure out when I was
looking in the literature like what I
could understand more about spiritual
not religious people and discovered that
the literature in sociology it was a
little bit in religious studies was very
quantitative in the sense that there
were a lot of survey research so I mean
how do you find the spiritual not
religious people you have to like go out
and find them by surveying then it
wasn't very clear since everyone assumes
that they're individualists that they
don't go participate in groups that they
don't have a certain kind of shared life
together so I had the opportunity in
Cambridge to actually go out and figure
out whether or not this was right and I
decided that actually probably wasn't
because sociologists and religious
studies scholars know or attend to say
if we don't know we tend to explore is
the ways that religious ideas or
spiritual ideas are actually learned and
taught that we don't usually think of
this as stuff that people just sort of
experience without some kind of social
or cultural connection or relationship
so so in cambridge i went and i
discovered actually that many of the
people who are spiritual not religious
are in fact you know very involved in
all kinds of group practices or are
there partaking in certain kinds of
classes and so on where they actually
are learning to be spiritual so they
also learned to say that they aren't
learning
they actually learn to say that their
individualists and they're following
their own path so it's really hard
sometimes actually through interviews
alone or through it are through I'm
surveys to actually understand where the
sort of social support for these kinds
of spiritual identities are being
developed and that's what ethnography
actually allowed me to do to say okay
here at the institutions and here are
the spaces here are the settings and
here are their connections to a longer
range of American religious ideas about
freedom and about individualism and
about prosperity and all of these things
so that's what the project was and i
think it was actually quite a timely
project in the sense that then while i
was doing the research there was in this
ethnographic way there was a body of
research that was also building on the
quantitative side that shows that i
remarkably there's been a remarkable
boom in the number of americans who say
their spiritual not religious so in the
last 30 years it's going from something
people who say they have no religious
preference yet still believe in God has
gone from something around five percent
of the population to now over twenty
percent of the population or close to
depending on what which of these surveys
you're looking at so this book actually
is important in the sense that it allows
it provide some context and a way to
think about the shifts that we see and
the experiences that many Americans are
having and they say that their spiritual
not religious so that's the beginning of
an answer to that question